on to
uh one through three i'm gonna put it on
you so no matter what happens it's your
fault
uh three one two
three all right this is on you
this is on you oh you're gonna love this
uh people always go hey how about
something for the fellas
and i got something for the fellows who
says that um
this 1920s uh huckster that i know
what is this i'm on tinder to find young
lovers
i'm comfortable not wearing underwear
though oh
god damn it she's 83 she's 83.
and also macron's wife
she's an older lady very old
a much older lady for drinks
if it seems like it's going to be good
we'll go right up to my apartment
and i just mike there's a reason i
played this [ __ ] there's certain dudes
that she also likes
certain kind of boy toys
how are you and we make love
[Music]
by the way this show is utter degenerate
oh i know oh extreme love oh i know
ah she's really old too this isn't like
83 man i'm not gonna lie like you know
that you see some older
sometimes you're like she can get it man
there are some older brothers out there
that could get it
this is an old lady look at the hands
the hands
that's this is an old lady this is not
my name is hattie and uh i'm 83 years
old
i think i know more about male's
genitalia then
did she even have she even has the the
horrible
i am it's just like when you're
when your entire crippled withering body
consists of mostly after-market parts
you know what i mean it's
you could like it's like when you get a
whole bunch of aftermarket [ __ ] in a car
and it's like none of this fits right
it's all weird
she's [ __ ] falling apart here she's
an 83 toyota corolla
and with a body kit exactly
you're a puerto rican car exactly
wouldn't you be afraid of like let's get
into the mechanics here for a second as
much as i don't want to we have to get
under the hood here
wouldn't you be afraid of like breaking
your hips or whatever like
i get like oh man i'm a [ __ ] chicks but
even if you're like a really lonely dude
and you still like you'll figure look
i'll [ __ ] this 83 year old
wouldn't you be afraid of like hurting
her or breaking her or killing her
yeah that's that level to it too yeah
that's that's also really weird to me
it's like
i've had i've had girls that were young
and cute but that were just that size
and you're like i don't want to kill you
you know what i mean like you know
you've got girls that are like
you know in their 20s but they're just
like that chick kelsea i was [ __ ]
with for a while she was like
five one and ten like petite blonde
chick and it was
yeah man i'm not a big powerful guy but
it's like you're tiny
and then she forgets to take her boniva
once and you killed her like that's not
worth it
it's not i may not know me i knew a
chick one time
that i worked with back in the day and
she was dating an older guy
she was older anyway she was like 40 but
she was dating a guy like
50 60 whatever right and uh but they
she was like a wild chick back in the
day so she was
[ __ ] this dude and i guess she's like
they were getting really into it she
let them [ __ ] her in the ass they were
getting like really crazy with it and he
started having a heart attack
but it was like a mild mild one right he
had to take the nitro and he had to like
lay down and
she's like yeah man it's not that makes
you feel older than my
[ __ ] dude's [ __ ] in the ass and he
has to take nitro because he's almost
had a heart attack you're [ __ ] old
you're [ __ ] evil biff tannen so it's
not even bones and stuff too you
you just just have a heart attack like
these people have heart attacks going to
get the male
yeah more than a gay man but
i do i know i know about god yeah
[Music]
okay oh there's also a microsoft product
placement in this video this lady trying
to hunch over and use your life look
they're trying her
they're trying to make her look like a
fun millennial just chilling in their
mouth and it's
not she looks like when frank dressed up
as the trash man
like that's her body you know what i
mean in the bali garbage
she looks like she will walk in a hot
parking lot all day too with bare feet
dirty foot uh she looks like she robbed
the tommy bahamas
[Laughter]
she you know what she's dressed like
she's dressed like the cover of a john
tesh album
her house looks like every airbnb in the
outer banks of north carolina
it's decorated exactly like every beach
house in north carolina you're right
you're absolutely right
paddy how much you want to bet she has a
jar of sand in the bathroom like
decorative sand
that's right you know you know exactly
says key west florida
exactly man like 20 2010
that's her picture in a cool leather
jacket 83
fascinating older beauty
is seeking a statement i took like three
years off because guys don't really like
86 year old women all right this isn't
her this is milo in 20 years
milo in five years if he keeps it up
[Laughter]
younger friend look at that look at that
bod are you not gonna check look at that
hot dog don't get me wrong look for an
80-something year old lady
you are you look healthy you look like
you know look i know 83 year old i know
70 something year olds that are like
they're just done uh
you want your grandma to to look like
this rashika told her because she means
she's healthy you just don't want her to
go [ __ ] a bunch of dudes
yeah no i if if your grandma looked like
this and she's like tonight me and my
friends we're going to benihana
or go out we're going to see cirque du
soleil and you're like my grandmother's
life rules
somebody's point we should [ __ ] hook
her up with politics suck guy
but like when she power couple but when
she you know i mean it's like one thing
to be like oh going out for
you know me and my friends are gonna
have a dinner party and you're like how
cool my grandma's still
out at it enjoying life it's another be
like i'm on tinder trying to get dicks
ugh grandma stop love her
for a shared life of adventure and
passion no pro trump
she still dresses like it's the 40s
sorry sorry you got to hear this part
you get you
this is this is for what a tinder bio
says beauty
is seeking a steady younger friend
lover for a shared life of adventure and
passion
no pro-trump and no players no approach
from
and it's
and no players but by the way this whole
trump thing at this point it's not just
marketing it's not just hip culture
people just not just hip to hate trump
it's not that no he's really a bad man
it's first off nothing she does is hip
except for her fake hips that she has
like that's the only hip but she's like
trying to emulate what she
thinks young people of course yeah
you're right even the haircut whole
culture
just you're all so cringe look at the
haircut she even has one of those
[ __ ] uh
suicide girl haircuts yeah but it looks
uh
it looks more like uh like she cut her
own hair looks like john hickman
it looks like she cut it with a
malfunctioning flowbee
do you only date younger men well first
of all most men my age
aren't around anymore older maybe like
you know
take the hint maybe understand that like
life's about more than this [ __ ]
getting dick [ __ ] i know this is a small
thing but look at her phone
and look how she has her apps arranged
look at her phone
it's just she's
she just has the email thing thrown
there
contacts over to the right a cup like
bumble and tinder you're right but
they're like sporadically thrown it's
almost like she shouldn't be using this
technology it's like a jitterbug
you know you know when you like get a
phone like with metropcs or one of like
the
boost tell you oh yeah you get a samsung
but it's not like an
it's not like an s10 it's like a j10 or
a q10 it's not it's not the right letter
or sometimes it just says get a free
smartphone exactly that's
the worst one because that one they're
not beholden at just yeah i don't know
what do you got to get an
lg from 2008 give them that gives
worried about aging and that makes sense
somebody just pointed out it's a mint
condition s4
mike hero her boombox not only plays cds
but it plays tapes
just really feels like i'm looking at a
b airplane airbnb it's like it's an air
b
it's an airbn it's it's every airbnb in
the south you're right because
everyone in south florida looks like
this anyone buy a beach
key west airbnb at aging everyone is
worried about aging
you think she has a combo dvd vhs in the
living room like
our airbnb did in holiday i like to tape
things off the
tv sometimes still jag i don't know how
to do it
with the new computers but a younger guy
is
not thinking aging they're not afraid
well sometimes they'll lose an erection
because something goes wrong but
something goes wrong like you like like
they
like they suddenly realized they
realized that the
time space continuum is really a thing
and they just were grossed out
mostly they're not concerned that
they're not going to sometimes it's
because
uh sam beckett leaped into somebody's
body yeah sometimes it's because they
start asking her
questions about the great depression and
she doesn't
answer them properly be hard
and they're not going to be able to
deliver for the woman and younger men
i mean a while now they get off on
getting a woman off very different from
when i was younger
i've been on tinder for about eight
months and i
[ __ ] 500 guys
i like the ones with and you know look
we we we obviously [ __ ] on women a lot
because you deserve it
but now i'm going to
sometimes have to be a little bit fair
the dudes that are
[ __ ] her are the worst guard yeah
they're garb you're all
garbage like the dudes because we could
sit here and we go wow look how crazy it
is but the only reason this story's the
thing is
because dudes are [ __ ] her like and
young dudes are [ __ ] her and look
we've all
i think we've all had a cougar at some
point in our lives yeah no i'm not a
saber tooth though mike
but not a [ __ ] yeah not a preserved
fossil yeah this
is like
you could start jurassic park from
what's in her socks and smiles
um and that look healthy see now this
guy says he's 57 he's probably
26.
i can't see the picture because it's
blurred out but just looking at the
bottom of his face that guy's 57.
you just have no concept of of age
anymore yeah you're like dr manhattan
yeah yeah you just don't know anymore
yeah
what's happening in front of you what
happened in the past
what's gonna happen in the future it's
almost that old now it's all muddled
[Laughter]
but he purposely does that uh now this
guy
this guy how dare you laugh at anybody
on tinder by the way
his mother so i don't think that
his mother's alive
to men a lot of their life's work has
already been achieved
i love younger men because they're in
the middle of an
achievement of a goal is the excitement
they want to be their biggest regret
they're not going to die soon creating
i'm still creating and i'm still moving
forward on
what are you creating nothing besides
[ __ ] nightmares what are what is
inside
besides nightmares what are you creating
my life goal and it's exciting oh look
he came up okay so let's see what he
looks like
they love giving orders it's a russian
spot farm lance
what's going on you know how many guys
swipe right because of the goof
there's got to be a goof factor too
where there's those guys like all right
this can't be real i got to see
also the guys that are running into her
what's your age filter on tinder like
you have it up to 100.
i love getting them so now i have a
steady stream yeah it doesn't even set
it
by the way if you have your age filter
set that high you had to set it that
high
yeah it's not manually yeah it defaults
to a certain group
yeah and it's not it's not [ __ ] a
hundred
i didn't mean to put it that way i have
a steady
uh selection of young men
this tall guy from ecuador he was
attracted to me
i said okay and he wanted a green card
let's go should we go to my apartment
let's go [ __ ] at the justice of the
peace
and i said why do you want to go there
it was very weird he told me to sign a
paper i didn't know what it was
and then after i said him by the way how
old are you
and he says 19.
that's hilarious you ruined somebody
who's still
basically a child you evil witch
and i didn't know he was 19 because i
probably and by the way she's looking
younger right here because she's wearing
the melisandre necklace once she takes
it off she's
even oh yeah it's crazy she's just dust
[Music]
yeah
okay so my feet are in and i lie back
somebody just said anthony coomie's mom
just came back
which is snow that's [ __ ] up because
that actually kind of looks like rope
it does that's just mean sir
congratulations for everything and it
takes all the stress off
this is good that is a great i just love
this that's it
i love this [ __ ] the scenario now
that's been
put out into the ether of anthony
kumia's
mother comes back from the dead as a
zombie
to [ __ ] young guys and act exactly like
him
and just make him disgusting right come
back
and just pound bud lights and eat xanax
and just
[ __ ] young dudes and be bite them and
[ __ ] get to
get shoot get their guns taken away be
like all right mom you win
stop logical
i skipped forward a little bit here
because i wanted to get into the date he
called
a heart attack to me and what you do is
you
cut the connection between your heart
and
and then fine okay
isn't this like
what do you what do you think what
extreme love is doing is elder abuse
what it is is is this this woman
probably she's obviously got no kids
she chose a life that was probably very
meaningless
uh and if you don't have
a family you can't prove like
be prevented from embarrassing yourself
we're doing no one's there help stopping
you yeah
like they like at some point we just
kind of destroyed the nuclear family as
a whole and anybody that doesn't come
from one ends up in some way
ends up either this lady or [ __ ] this
lady you know what i mean it's just
[ __ ] man nobody's around to go grandma
stop
do you like this do you like it
sweetheart
that cat's going to be eating our face
one day i'm comfortable not wearing
underwear though
okay i'm all right now tell me about the
day you have coming up tonight
his name is sean
[Laughter]
hell yeah you were nine girl
oh man this is gonna looks like big
boy's son of course it is it looks like
it looks like one of the guys that would
have been in the cast of straight out of
compton
like not any of the original nwa members
but he just looks like
somebody in the death row studio yeah he
looks like the guy
he looks like somebody who would have
played m.c wren
we'll eat we'll talk we'll probably kiss
we'll see
but it's sweet beauty bye sweetheart
yeah so you paying right you know hell
and i'll probably give him a massage and
he's going to give me a massage
so there is the intimacy whether or not
something will happen
i don't really know
[Music]
look at the wall right now it's even an
old lady walk
face time have you ever done it hi mom
oh my god you were wrong
she has kids i take it back she has
yeah look she has kids mike
i i'm shocked i'm not you know what man
look
ali i'll eat [ __ ] when i'm wrong i was
wrong
but it seemed it seemed like she had all
the indicators
before yeah of course
well i'm only a mother what should i
know
but anyway darling so we're standing in
front of them her daughter's kind of
young
for her to be in her 80s did she have
her daughter when she was 63
a restaurant and there's this guy who i
asked
a bunch of questions because i said he
married he said no i said are you gay he
said no
i said are you an addict he said no i
said will you go on a date with me he
said yes
so here i am sounds like a fun day so
are you ever embarrassed about me
no at once once you told me you
were in a dorm at nyu and that i thought
was pushing
the nyu guys right
so we blamed the daughter right oh god
i've eaten there what place is this
i don't remember the name of it but
that's that red that red door this is
actually my one of my first experiences
with an older woman
well why don't you [ __ ] start at like
work your way 40 man ease your way into
the [ __ ] you know
this is a just dive in the pool kind of
guy right say this is a fantasy just
because i haven't been
too in tune with the older crowd and
such but yeah i was considering the
fantasy
this is one of those places where you
get like a [ __ ] you know 17
cobb salad and it's not even good okay
yeah
like what's the point i don't mind out
paying outrageous prices but i want
you know delicious truffle butter on my
steak like yeah it's this is
is it it looks like it's probably near
midtown right this is a kind of a
touristy yeah yeah
i wonder if like if this were real life
too but you know how many people come up
and go
ma'am is he bothering you yeah you're
right stop asking our customers for
money
i told you to get out of here i'm
actually here on a date with this lady
oh it's so bad i would pay
somebody to go up to them and say that
if i were in that restaurant go up to
them and be like hey stop
bothering our customers asking for money
look at her are her arthritic fingers
about to touch him
[Music]
when he picked up the ring
then one man for my everything
didn't happen you know back when i was
young you had to sit at a different part
of the bar
somebody says oh you're about to rob her
that's actually kind of funny could you
imagine if this guy met her on tinder
and was planning on robbing her and then
there's a camera crew there
and now he has to do the date i gotta go
on a date with him oh no
i'm stuck look can i be honest with you
look man yeah i was gonna rob this lady
okay
and like i didn't do anything yet so i
can still leave
but i wasn't gonna [ __ ] her and he just
leaves
yeah so i miss making love which is
crazy because you're an amazing person
so
yeah yeah somebody missed out
[Music]
she keeps touching him most i like about
hattie was her bubbling personality and
how genuine she is
oh he [ __ ] her didn't he yes she's
just a people person
the date went well um it's interesting
dynamic
uh coming from what i'm used to but you
know
all in all i would say it was it was
pretty cool
she paid probably yeah she's definitely
an interesting person you have no
choice but to run into hattie this was
fun
dc in the chat i'm sorry
this is one of the funniest things i've
ever this might be one of the funniest
comments i've ever read in history
it's like getting grabbed by a
de-skinned terminator
a t-800 a de-skinned
terminator
that's mean it's mean it's just cold and
metallic
sean is an absolute darling
so he didn't [ __ ] her you didn't [ __ ]
her he didn't [ __ ] her
i don't think i think he really was
going to rob her that or i think that he
really didn't think the camera crew is
going to be there
yeah i could get you to sign a release
on the spot yeah you're of course
yeah of course very sexual man i'm a
very sexual woman
and there's no what if she's an insult
what if she's just lying about getting
all this dick and she's not getting
anything what if literally nobody's
[ __ ] her
like they have these pickup artist types
that i think are lying half the time
anyway
like roof v and all those guys right
what if she's an
old lady masquerading as this yeah i'm
just
out here getting all these dicks and
like nobody's [ __ ] her nobody and
then she even was like i'm gonna be on
the show
and i'm gonna show him how much dick i
get and then on the show she doesn't
even get the dick
wait until one of these guys boys sees
the video and they start [ __ ] with
him